a new ring
how did it come to you why did it Choose
You
[Music]
here is Middle Earth yes the free to
play turn-based strategy RPG that brings
together an endless assortment of
classic characters from the Tolkien
Universe in a strategic social
competitive mobile experience the new
rig very interesting aspect of our game
what the ring does is it grants the
player the ability to bring the best
characters the characters that he feels
best suit that battle that's going to
happen in that location and somewhat you
know push the bounds of what is the
narrative Canon and allow for the
players to sort of experience things in
a new and fresh way but within the
larger story that we're presenting and
the larger sort of conceit within the
game it will make much more sense once
players dive into it this ring will will
of course be a big part of that there's
such a depth of Storytelling to use in
such a way that combines both narrative
and gameplay mechanics so players are
constantly challenging new and
surprising ways that's a big part of why
we chose to expand the narrative both to
serve the familiar stories
but also intertwine them with gameplay
design in a way that'll keep the game
fun and imaginative over time you've
seen Frodo you've seen Sam you've seen
Legolas that's only a really small
sampling of course you know some of the
most iconic characters we have
characters that range from you know the
entire timeline from all of those
stories and we've also expanded out
races and factions within that so
players can really experience them in a
way that they probably haven't to to
date our combat is turn-based strategy
players can hone their skills across the
game using the story mode and the PVP
mode they can design teams around unique
combat skills and abilities to win
battles and they can also play to
character relationships and
personalities to unlock team-ups and
Synergy bonuses reinforcing friendships
families and rivalries I would describe
our art style as a form of stylized
realism but what that means for us is
that we have characters and environments
that are simplified they're not
caricatured they're grounded but they're
quite fantastic if you go back even
further you know our art style is
actually quite close to the original Ip
tolkien's own original watercolor
illustrations of Middle Earth are very
bright they're very colorful they're
heavily stylized and we take that as a
point of inspiration it's interesting
you know developing yourself with some
characters who have very little written
about them
you know how does one do that we take a
race we take a faction like uh herodrim
um who have some things written about
them you can come up with details but
how do we realize that into something
that we feel is unique and appealing at
the same time we do that a lot by simply
making sure that that the style is
something clear and legible it's going
to read really well on a mobile device
we are not ready quite yet to share our
worldwide launch timeline just yet but
players should stay tuned as we continue
our soft launch rollout and select
countries around the world
foreign